thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
the victor
of the superbad chess classic the first
leg of the grand chess tour 2021
chakriar
mamadiar of shaq first of all
congratulations what an amazing
tournament for you
tell us what are your first feelings i
am
very happy to win first time is the
grand third tournament
won one of the tournaments of course
this
form is more important classical
tournaments because not easy to win
any classical tournaments and super
tournaments
okay i'm very happy i want to say
i wanted to say many things for my
uh friends also
is mr jerome who is from ireland
ireland is watching me in from gossip
he supports me too much every day and
it's very important for me
and if my not friend is
my brother's whistle who was here with
me in tournament
and his joker family and his joker's
birthday today and
i give him his willing for joker
joko so you're a big fan of tennis
no not he's not joking jack is just
playing he's young chess players he's
from rumunia
he's from here and they just were
good with his friends family i just want
to say congratulations
thursday and it's win for him and for mr
yellow
almirah was uh mentioning that this was
almost
as she was watching your games it was
almost a victory
of a spirit over the engines did you
feel like that uh playing this
tournament
okay i i i prefer very
serious that this tournament and every
day here is to today also i perform for
seven hours in the games i don't know i
cannot sleep in a
whole day and i think i never think he
will play like
1993 and okay i mean
he was after after quality
we had more times for the preparing word
chest
openings everything and for this reason
i'm very happy to come tournament in
good form
and very good to win
tournament like these were strong
i want to say thank you also it's war
sponsors for our gains us
is very good hotel tournament hall is
everyone is very friendly thank you very
much for you for
our commentators so you're very good we
will enjoy from your commenters
thank you very much it was a pleasure uh
to see you play this
brilliant chess we'll see you later on
to hand you the trophy
but for the moment congratulations and
we'll throw it back in the studio
thank you very much guys back thank you
christian once again our congratulations
to a very deserved winner
shaq taking home the 90 thousand dollars
the 13
uh points the extra bonus grand chest
and putting them in pole position and
you can see here shakuya mahmed yaro
first first place 90
000.13 gct
points what a great performance here for
shock
it's difficult to win these tournaments
absolutely but
he came prepared he came hungry he had
this spirit
and a very deserved winner i i'm happy
to see shaq and i think we talked about
this halfway through the event
it's nice to see chris up there in the
standings